be careful miss dinosaurs everywhere and
they're flipping out and killing people
let's go hey everybody it's Charlie this
is gonna be my non-spoilery Jurassic
world fallen Kingdom review I talked a
little bit about it when I was doing my
Incredibles to non-spoilery review it
has some of the same good things and bad
things about it so still a pretty safe
bet in terms of big summer blockbuster
but you may hear people complaining
about some very specific things so I'll
try to address that during this but if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
there's a whole bunch of stuff that's
gonna be happening this summer
especially as we ramp up for comic-con
overall the movie starts out really
strong it has some great action scenes
and then sort of starts to fizzle as you
get to the third act and especially the
ending the ending is what most people
are complaining about but I feel like
this doesn't completely ruin the film
like it does try to fix some of the
issues of the first Jurassic world film
but it never quite gets to some of the
highs that that film did the last
Jurassic world movie I still feel like
is a better movie overall now that we
actually have five Jurassic movies I
will be sure to write them all during
the video but for the most part they fix
some of the issues with Bryce Dallas
Howard character Chris Pratt's still
pretty steady performer like you know
you've seen him in infinity war and the
guardians movies so you know what he can
do when he gets really good material his
performance in this movie pretty
consistent with his character during the
first film but obviously the dinosaurs
are the real stars of the movie but
you're all wondering about Jeff Goldblum
so they brought Ian Malcolm back of the
scenes that he was in he did a great job
Jeff Goldblum is fantastic so it's just
funny to see him vacillate between Grand
Master in the Marvel movies just crazy
silly character to the more serious
scientist that plays the moral core of
this Jurassic series so they were pretty
consistent in the way that they wrote
his character like he did feel like Ian
Malcolm in the previous films but he
wasn't nearly as big a part of the film
as I expected him to be perhaps they'll
use him more in the next film obviously
there's gonna be another Jurassic world
film so I will address that at the end
of this without getting into spoilers
but because this is a franchise film
there's certain expectations that you
have like okay very clearly there gonna
be some beats to set up what the next
movie is going to be the
film does raise some interesting
questions about ethics like what are our
role in this situation where we created
crazy dinosaurs and do we have a
responsibility to take care of them or
because they're this aberration that was
created through Mad Science should we
just let them die I think going into the
film most people will have already made
their mind up about that just depending
on how you feel about animals in general
like all life is precious or you don't
care about the dinosaurs like it's one
way or the other
I don't think it got too preachy with
its message it doesn't forget that it is
a big summer blockbuster so it doesn't
spend too much time on that like I said
you get a lot of that moralizing through
the Ian Malcolm character and there
wasn't nearly as much of him in the film
as I expected based on the trailers I
don't want to say the trailers are
misleading because they don't go full
Marvel infinity war like there isn't
fake stuff that they see g'd into the
trailers no surprise I had a couple
issues with villain character
development that's a pretty common
complaint to big summer blockbuster
movies this movie is no different the
villain is mostly a cipher character and
then they did try to retcon more aspects
from the new films into continuity with
the original film they do try to wrap up
dr. Wu's arc because he has this mad
scientist arc that's been going across
multiple films so I believe Colin
Trevorrow has already said that they're
not gonna do any crazy hybrid dinosaurs
in the next Jurassic world film the
actual hybrid of this film of the Indo
Raptor that you see during the trailers
is an interesting idea but I wasn't
totally happy with what they did with
that character obviously the t-rex is
still a big hero in the film you get a
little bit of that during the trailer
they use it in relatively the same way
they did in the last Jurassic world
though did you find a way to recycle
some of the big plot beats and the funny
holy crap moments from the first
Jurassic world film for better or worse
some of you might cringe at that some of
you might be excited by it if you really
liked it in that last film there's some
really strong Raptor moments that it
carries forward from the last film like
you have the blue Raptor that Chris
Pratt has the connection to Chris Pratt
has a relatively strong arc in the film
and like I said there's this overarching
theme about what's our responsibility to
these dinosaurs so there were some good
Raptor moments because of that but boy
are there some ridiculous twist towards
the end of the film so just over
all I feel like the film is still like I
said good summer blockbuster it delivers
on the thrills and you understand when I
rank all my Jurassic series movies how
it does beat out some of the original
Jurassic Park sequels but it just never
quite gets to the levels that the
original Jurassic world movie got to
which had its own issues but I felt like
overall as the film did a pretty solid
job within the Jurassic series so I did
enjoy the original Jurassic world movie
and I feel like they have pretty strong
footing for the next Jurassic world
movie whatever they're going to end up
calling that but there's just a lot of
things about this Jurassic world fallen
Kingdom movie that feel like they're in
between transitional elements like we
want to get to this next story but we
have to explain how we get to there so
we have to spend an entire movie doing
that so a lot of you will walk out of
the film going you know why don't we
just start with the plot beat at the end
of the film instead of doing all the
stuff in between in funny story speaking
of plot beats Chris Pratt told this
story that Tom Holland on the set of
infinity war spoiled this movie for him
before he ever started making it so way
back a couple years ago they're filming
spider-man homecoming in guardians of
the galaxy volume 2 on the same sets
like right next to each other in the
same studio so Tom Holland is hanging
out with Chris Pratt and he's friends
with the director of Jurassic world
fallen Kingdom so he tells Chris Pratt
oh man my mate told me all about the
movie that you guys are getting ready to
make and proceeded to tell him all the
big plot twists that the director had
told Tom Hollands so Chris Pratt is like
I learned all about this movie before I
ever read the script thanks to Tom
Holland mr. spoiler himself the first I
heard about the plot was from Tom
Holland weirdly close Tom I was doing I
think I was doing shooting a sequel for
guardians of the galaxy maybe and Tom
was doing spider-man I think on the same
lot Tom of course knows Jay Bayona
because of the film the impossible and
Tom was the young guy in that in that
movie and he's so growing up now but uh
he said hey mate I just talked to Jay a
mate he told me the whole plot of this
story I was like what
yeah there's like a volcano I was like
shut you're messing with me he's like no
I mean he told me the whole thing so he
told me the whole story
so I heard it right from Tom Holland
first and then and then you know when I
read the script I was like yeah he
wasn't me I love Chris Pratt's Tom
Holland impression sends a little more
like Australian Tom Holland so just
ranking this film overall in the
Jurassic world series favorite film is
still the original Jurassic Park film
still one of the best movies of all time
then Jurassic world one then sort of
this vast drop-off of Jurassic world
fallen Kingdom Jurassic Park - then
obviously my least favorite film
Jurassic Park 3 the reason why I ranked
fallen Kingdom above the original
Jurassic Park sequels is is because it
has a lot of similar story problems but
it delivers on the thrills in the way
that those Jurassic Park sequels did not
there's been way more time in fallen
Kingdom dedicated to big action scenes
and some of them are genuinely good the
film itself is shot much better is much
better looking than the original
Jurassic world movie but from a story
level it just doesn't quite get there so
once you do have a chance to see it just
let me know what you think of it in the
comments below it should be rolling out
to theaters to pretty much everybody
this weekend although I think it was
released internationally a couple weeks
ago so most of you outside of the United
States probably saw this quite a bit ago
but what will happen is is there was a
bunch of infinity war behind the scenes
stuff that drops so I'll post that over
the next couple of days there's also a
bunch of big news that just dropped
everybody's wondering about this Disney
Fox deal so I'll try to do videos for
all that stuff leave all your requests
in the comments below click here for
brand new spider-man and click here for
my Incredibles to review thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight